donc bon soir le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
bienvenue dans cette édition du journal
du lundi 31 mai voici les titres depuis
aujourd'hui la vaccination contre le coc
vivent 19 et ouverte à tous les plus de
18 ans sans critères de santé nouvelle
étape dans cette campagne qui a débuté
fin 2020 nous serons depuis le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines où
les personnes on a plus aujourd'hui pour
recevoir une première injection
chaque année 800 millions de tonnes de
déchets sont produites en france face à
ce constat la filière du réemploi fait
de plus en plus d'adeptes avec des
initiatives locales leur hyper café de
magny les hameaux a ouvert ses portes ce
week-end invité de ce journal également
eric les gatineau directeurs d'ems vite
rappelé à structure rénovée relevant les
équipements électriques et électroniques
et puis c'est parti pour le premier
naturel aventure sera les 100 %
électrique et 100% féminin a effectué
hier un départ fictif depuis versailles
c'était en présence du parrain de
l'événement l'humoriste franck dubosc
labellisation gault et millau pour le
restaurant de l'epa du chéné rocancourt
c'est également au programme de ce
journal rester avec nous
une injection possible dès 18 ans et ce
sans critères de santé la campagne de
vaccination contre le coc vie de 19
s'élargit à partir d'aujourd'hui est
l'objectif pour le gouvernement à
atteindre les 30 millions de primo
vacciner à la mi juin au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les premiers rendez vous on taffe lui et
aujourd'hui on retrouve sur place astrid
berges r oui grégory 3000 personnes ont
été vaccinées aujourd'hui ici au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ce 31 mai c'était une date attendue à
partir d'aujourd'hui toutes les
personnes âgées d'au moins 18 ans sans
critères d'état de santé peuvent se
faire vacciner
plus besoin d'attendre le soir pour
trouver un créneau pour le lendemain
3000 injection aujourd'hui mais aussi
demain et les autres jours de la semaine
le rythme sera le même et d'ailleurs au
moment où je vous parle des créneaux
sont encore disponibles pour les
prochains jours ici au vélodrome
il suffit de prendre rendez-vous grâce à
l'application d'octo libre pour rappel
le gouvernement souhaite atteindre la
barre des 30 millions de primo vacciner
d'ici mi juin
ce jour marque donc une nouvelle étape
dans cette campagne de vaccination la
prochaine étape prévue courant juin sera
la vaccination des 16-17 ans astrid
berges heures depuis le vélodrome
national avec bérengère bourgoin pour
les moyens techniques
en plus du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un deuxième
vaccinodromes va ouvrir ses portes dans
le département il sera installé dans le
hall 5 du parc des expositions de mantes
la jolie
situé sur l'île aumône le site de 1000
mètres carrés sera géré par la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise avec le partenariat de
l'association odyssée l agence régionale
de santé
6000 injections seront réalisés à partir
de demain et ce par semaine sur place
avec l'objectif est d'atteindre une
cadence de 8000 injection par semaine à
terme le centre sera ouvert du lundi au
samedi de 9 heures à 18 heures et sera
accessible uniquement sur rendez vous
ils sont à prendre et via le site d'octo
libre.fr une campagne de vaccination qui
se poursuit dès indicateurs de
l'épidémie qui baissent dans le même
temps dans les yvelines
regardez ces chiffres collectés sur une
semaine large recul du taux d'incidence
nombreux nombre de nouveaux contaminée
pour cent mille habitants
il s'établit désormais à 113,9 - 57,4 en
une semaine du côté des données
hospitalières la tension continue de se
desserrer en réanimation
131 passion était toujours hospitalisé
hier dans les yvelines soit 90 en moins
par rapport à il ya une semaine et
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
1805 personnes sont mortes du colis de
19 dans les hôpitaux du département et
dans l'actualité également le dernier
conseil communautaire de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines jeudi
dernier les élus ont voté une convention
avec l'état pour la réalisation d'une
étude complémentaire pour le
réaménagement du carrefour de la malle
me donne ce projet urbain à
l'intersection de coignières la verrière
et maurepas doit voir le jour à
l'horizon 2000 26 mai la question du
financement reste le point avec nicolas
doit permettre aux automobilistes de
relier les villes de coignières maurepas
à la verrière grâce à un pot au dessus
de la nationale 10 c'est l'un des
objectifs du réaménagement du carrefour
de la malle me donne d'après une étude
la nationale 10 supporte un trafic de
l'ordre de 52 mille véhicules par jour
dans cette zone ce projet est nécessaire
pour fluidifier la circulation
mais une question persiste sur le
financement de l'opération estimée à 25
millions d'euros
on a le financement de l'agglo bien
entendu rdda le financement du
département
on a le financement de l'état mais tout
cela ne fait pas 25 millions et le
projet est à 25 millions ça fait une
vingtaine de millions quid du
financement régional qu'elle va faire la
région cette question a été abordée lors
du conseil d'agglomération du jeudi 27
mai mais le président jean-michel
fourgous se veut rassurant c'est en
discussion comme on dit favorable ne
tombe que et que médée cette période
extrêmement controversée de cette crise
sanitaire pour l'instant on a pas
d'abandon des ans des engagements de nos
partenaires une enquête publique devrait
être lancée début 2000 22 les travaux du
réaménagement du carrefour de la malle
me donne devrait commencer en 2024 pour
une livraison prévue à l'horizon 2026
fini de jeter ces objets du quotidien
dès qu'ils sont en panne que ce soit
pour le petit électroménager des
ordinateurs ou encore et des vélos il
est possible de les réparer grâce aux
bénévoles du nouveau harry père café à
magny les hameaux
il a ouvert ses portes samedi dernier
dans la commune le reportage dasri
bergère et de mélanie potiche apprendre
à réparer ces objets plutôt que de les
jeter c'est tout l'objectif du nouveau
rippert café de magny les hameaux les
réparations lieu dans un local mis à
disposition par la mairie
c'était une forte demande des habitants
depuis quelques temps et en fait on a eu
la chance que deux associations et la
même envie au même moment donc vivre à
manille et maniant transition donc voilà
que les planètes se sont alignés en a
profité et ces échanges de savoir-faire
sous totalement gratuit réalisé c'est
robert café y en a trois il ya d'abord
la lutte contre le gaspillage
et la participation à ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l' indice de réparabilité
donc de conforter cette démarche là où
un deuxième est l'objectif qui est de
transmettre des compétences et les
savoir-faire est elle un troisième qui
est peut-être encore plus important qui
est création le maintien le
développement de relations sociales
le concept plaît c'est samedi 29 mai les
bénévoles ont aidé les habitants des
environs à réparer des machines à coudre
des jouets ou encore du matériel
informatique
j'ai apporté mon imprimante parce que
fonctionne plus qu'à moitié
à chaque fois que j'ai appris ça sort
des feuilles blanches
je laissais préparée et j'y arrive pas
ok je tente ma chance ici puisque
j'aimais bien le côté de bénévolat ici
je trouve ça génial comme principe que
que des gens nous aident à réparer des
objets pour éviter que crochète ça alors
que c'est encore fonctionnel leur hyper
café devrait ouvrir un samedi par mois
les associations cherchent toujours des
outils fonctionnels et des bénévoles
en france 800 millions de tonnes de
déchets sont produits par an parmi
lesquels des vêtements des meubles mais
aussi des appareils électroménagers qui
pourrait faire l'objet d'une seconde vie
on continue la discussion avec eric
gatineau qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir à vous
êtes le directeur d'envy trappe alors le
réseau envie c'est une cinquantaine
d'entreprises en france dans l'insertion
sur le territoire et qui est spécialisée
dans le recyclage et la réparation
d'équipements électriques et
électroniques
selon l'ademe l'agencé de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie 85% des français en envisager
l'éventualité de faire réparer leurs
appareils avant d'en changer
finalement seuls 36% le font le reste
remplace ces appareils le projet dans
vie au delà de l'insertion dont on va
parler dans un instant est ce que
finalement c'est aussi d'insuffler
d'encourager de nouvelles manières de
consommer oui tout à fait le projet de
rvi c'est de contribuer à faire évoluer
et à faire changer des modes de
consommation dans le sort d'une
consommation plus raisonnée plus
responsable et en particulier d'éviter
le gaspillage de prolonger la durée de
vie du raid usage des appareils
électroménagers ça fait complètement
partie de notre travail en dehors de
notre métier de réparateur professionnel
on va dire on a une activité de
sensibilisation du grand public sur ces
thématiques
alors je précise d'ailleurs que depuis
le 1er janvier un indice de réparabilité
a fait son apparition cette note 22,1 à
10 et permet de savoir en un coup d'oeil
ainsi un lave linge à une télé un
ordinateur portable ou même un
smartphone sont facilement réparable
alors envie trappe c'est une association
on va parler de votre activité
mais un volet important c'est
l'insertion professionnelle une partie
de vos salariés dans un parcours de
retour vers l'emploi
c'est ça oui c'est plus de la moitié de
nos salariés aujourd'hui on n'est pas
plus de 40 personnes a travaillé sur le
site de trappes
une association qui a 9 ans d'existence
désormais et dans notre adn
depuis l'origine j'ai envie notre notre
métier est de remettre au travail de
remettre le pied à l'étrier à des
personnes qui est éloigné en turquie ou
du travail
il va permettre de d'acquérir de
nouvelles compétences de reprendre
confiance de également se réinsérer dans
un collectif en vue d'un retour à
l'emploi durable alors sorti de
l'association donc c'est leur jeu de
social en plus de l'enjeu
environnemental qui est poursuivi par
notre association
combien de personnes actuellement sur le
site envies attrape au vol 42 personnes
fait en deux personnes travaillent sur
le site et plus de la moitié en
insertion même si on a beaucoup
développé également les emplois dits
permanent avec le recrutement de huit
cdi en moins d'un an
vous parlez de ces personnes en
réinsertion le profil justement de ces
personnes il est divers oui d'ailleurs
vous parlez de réinsertion qui est
plutôt en général ne sont rattachés à la
sortie d'un bar commercial ce qui n'est
pas du tout le cas où très
minoritairement parmi nos salariés les
profits sont sont très divers donc non
on parle d'insertion et ce sont soit des
jeunes publics des gens qui n'ont sinon
parfois j'avais travaillé on a aussi des
anciens des gens qui ont été en quelque
sorte victimes d'accident de parcours de
leur carrière professionnelle
toutes présentent des fragilités des
difficultés d'ordre financier social de
santé ou autres et toutes ont besoin
d'un coup de pouce pour retrouver le
chemin de l'emploi
donc c est à ça que sert envie c'est
vraiment leur permettre de retrouver
ce chemin personnel et professionnel
pour s'insérer dans la société
vous avez bien fait de faire cette
précision comment sont-elles forme et
justement ces personnes on imagine que
la formation évolue parce qu'aujourd'hui
dans l'électroménager il ya de plus en
plus l'électronique
il ya aussi des appareils connectés
aujourd'hui donc les manières de réparer
aussi évolué
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est un
enjeu majeur dans notre activité c'est
la montée en compétence la
professionnalisation la formation
professionnelle de nos salariés
c'est vrai pour nous en cadrant c'est
vrai pour nos salariés en insertion les
technologies évoluées et envir adapte en
permanence ces parcours de formation là
le réseau envie se dote de nouvelles
ressources de formateurs très compétents
dans le domaine être ménagé aujourd'hui
le métier de technicien et qu'on ménage
est un métier qui est devenu un métier
en tension et nous nos jours notre carte
si je puis dire pour former faire monter
en compétences et proposer également des
suites de bach cours pour les pour les
personnes qui sont les plus aptes à
exercer ce métier on sur le site de
trappes quel type d'objet leçons sont
traités c'est l'électro ménager votre
spécialité c'est l'électroménager sur
site de trappes c'est plutôt du gros
électroménager
même si on a également une activité sur
sur du petit électroménager mais mais
principalement du gros électroménager
nous nous préparons et nous vendons
environ 3000 appareils par an cette
année on va sans doute plus approcher
les 4000 appareils par an et c'est
majoritairement ce qu'on appelle le
blanc des réfrigérateurs des cuisinières
des fours des laves l'âge de ses charges
de la vaisselle
comment les collectifs vous justement
ces appareils est concrètement une fois
que vous les avez collecté que se
passe-t-il que faites vous concrètement
nous les collectons majoritairement
auprès d'eux
deux distributeurs dans le cadre
d'accords avec un éco organisme qui
s'appelle écosystèmes ça représente à
peu près 90% nos approvisionnements tous
les jours nous allons collecter sur des
plateformes logistiques de distributeurs
entre 80 et 100 appareils
mais nous collectons aussi auprès des
particuliers lorsque nous avons livré
nos propres machines
nous récupérons les anciens matériels et
puis de plus en plus de personnes
viennent nous apporter des leurs anciens
produits soit directement en magasin
soit dans le cadre de collecte de
proximité que nous organisons en ile de
france et du coup une fois que vous les
avez récupéré très concrètement c'est de
la réparation du nettoyage avant de les
remettre sur le circuit oui c'est du tri
d'abord c'est décidé je trie on connaît
toutes sortes d'appareils
donc c'est un premier tri après c'est du
diagnostic sur la pad c'est de la
réparation qui comprend à la fois des
aspects curatifs de réparation de panne
et préventif pour changer des pièces qui
sont soumises à une mesure habituelle
donc pour rallonger la durée de vie de
l'appareil
beaucoup de nettoyage et ensuite c'est
la remise en vente en magasin avec une
garantie qui va de un an à 300 et avec
des prix qui sont 40 à 60% inférieur par
rapport à des objets neufs c'est ça oui
c'est la politique depuis toujours c'est
la politique dans vie c'est d'être
environ deux fois moins cher que le prix
du neuf avec des produits qui sont des
produits de qualité qui sont
sélectionnés aussi pour ça et avec un
vrai savoir-faire dans la réparation et
le reconditionnement de ses appareils
avec une gamme très large de produits
qui sont vendus à des prix qui sont
abordables pour tous et on retrouve
toutes les informations sur envie trappe
sur le site internet qui va s'afficher
sai s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
eric gatineau d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous et je rappelle vous êtes le
directeur d'envy trappe à guyancourt des
bénévoles se réunissent chaque semaine
pour ramasser les déchets présents dans
la ville autour du groupe
guyancourt objectif ville propre sur les
réseaux ils ont réussi à fédérer et 200
personnes résultats 28 mille litres de
déchets ont d'ores et déjà été ramassés
en quatre mois astrid berges heures pour
le reportage
tout a commencé par la création d'un
groupe facebook il ya quatre mois
guyancourt objectif ville propre réuni
200 personnes
ses habitants se retrouvent une fois par
semaine pour ramasser les déchets
présents dans la commune on trouve un
peu de tout mais quand je vous dis tout
ça peut être deux gros encombrants on en
ramasse et deux tonnes d'encombrants
c'est à dire des meubles des pneus une
poubelle des années 70 donc des déchets
qui sont là depuis très longtemps ou des
déchets très récent gants gilet
fluorescent gels hydroalcooliques pince
les bénévoles ont pu s'équiper en
matériel de protection grâce à des
partenariats avec des commerçants de
guyancourt 28 litres de déchets ont été
ramassées depuis quatre mois en fait ce
qui est désespérant plus je m'attendais
à des déchets mais je ne pensais pas
qu'il y avait autant gens qui de la
civilité c'est le fait de jeter ses
détritus paref net quoi donc des fois il
ya des fourrés et et on retrouve les
boîtes du mcdo on retrouve les
bouteilles de coca faire un massage du
déchet sont aussi l'occasion de passer
du temps en famille et de se balader
avec les enfants je viens d nettoyer
pour que la ville soit propre
enfin le playback on peut faire des
pique-niques on peut nettoyer la ville
devient très joli sylvie tellier qui
gère le groupe facebook a été convié à
un groupe de travail par la mairie pour
l'organisation de la journée autour de
l'écologie cleanup day qui devrait avoir
lieu en septembre
mais je vous en parlais en sortie de
titres tout à l'heure depuis décembre la
cuisine d'un ehpad du chéné rocancourt
est labellisé gault et millau du nom du
fameux guide gastronomique est l'airé
pas les repas sont à base de produits
frais si possible locaux et tout est
cuisiné sur place par le chef célia
garçons gauche apporte de la puissance
un petit caractère d'un petit peu de
grain petit peu d'acidité tomates mixer
confit d'oignons rouges
un apéritif validé par le responsable du
pôle audit et labellisation de gault et
millau
depuis décembre le chef cuisinier de
l'établissement corrie en ville à
saint-antoine aux chaînés rocancourt a
reçu le label du célèbre guide
gastronomique
il propose aux résidents des plats faits
sur place avec des produits frais nous
nos résidents ils sont pour nous ils
sont comme au restaurant tous les jours
pour avoir l'oreille l'écoutent du du
résident pour nous c'est des clients
pour obtenir la labellisation une visite
d'un inspecteur de gault et millau a
lieu dans l'établissement durant toute
une journée il goûte chaque plat texture
normale et mixez la cuisine pour une
grosse partie de la note le service
l'accueil la bienveillance sont des
critères tous ces critères mélanger
audités noté produisent
bilan final qui permet à l'établissement
de kabylie ou non aujourd'hui au menu du
jour pâté en entrée docks de boeuf à la
provençale et crème pâtissière les
résidents au courant de cette
labellisation ont des avis différents
c'est trop copieux vaudrait mieux que ce
soit moins copieux est meilleur c'est
varié c'est un bon cuisinier je retrouve
vraiment les saveurs d'avant parce que
si vous voulez gault et millau et peint
ci par là et moi toute ma jeunesse
j'étais abonnée à gault et millau
l'obtention de ce label valorise le
travail de l'équipe en cuisine c'est une
fierté pour la directrice de
l'établissement
gault et millau c'est surtout laventure
d'une équipe le souhait d'évoluer le
souhait de grandir dans du haut de gamme
et de proposer à nos résidents une
prestation de haute qualité
gault et millau a labellisé depuis 2007
plus de 80 ehpad korian dont un second
établissement dans les yvelines
la maison de retraite les saules à
guyancourt le sport pour refermer ce
journal avec le coup d'envoi de la
première édition de nature l aventure un
rallye 100% féminin en voiture
électrique
ce dimanche les binômes ont pris le bus
devant l'hôtel de ville de versailles
pour rejoindre le point de départ situé
en haute savoie justin brasier était sur
place naturelle aventure le premier
challenge électro féminin au monde et
yvelinois un rally d'une semaine à lyon
véhicules électriques et trekking ou
encore orientation dimanche les équipes
ont quitté versailles pour se lancer
officiellement dans la course ce lundi
31 mai le départ a été donné à annemasse
en haute-savoie un évènement 100%
féminin nos projets vraiment en faveur
de l'environnement en faveur de la
mobilité électrique est vraiment on a
souhaité dire qu'avec une voiture
électrique on est capable de faire un
rallye et parce qu'on est des femmes on
est également capable de s'orienter
objectif conduire de façon économe
franck dubosc parrain de cette première
édition soutient la cause depuis le
départ fictif à versailles
l'artiste s'est allié à ce projet en
faveur de l'environnement
allié à presque chaque événement donc
quelque chose écologique s'est montré à
tout le monde que
bac c'est important et puis qu'on peut
le faire surtout qu'on peut le faire et
que c'est assez facile de le faire
dallier l'écologie à n'importe quel
événement voilà donc je trouve que c'est
c'est une c'est une belle cause je
trouve que l'écologie surtout en ce
moment c'est une belle cause parce
qu'elle doit nous réunir tout ce n est
pas l ai pas clivante
douze équipes ont décidé de relever le
défi chaque binôme américaine de
formation pour apprendre à s'orienter en
challenge des connectés sans gps ni
téléphone mais avec carte et boussole
ce sera une expérience enrichissante de
d'orientation puisque ce soit en voiture
ou à pied lors des treks on a deux
cartes et boussoles et puis l'intérêt de
ce projet c'est que tout ce qu'on tout
l'argent qu'on a qu'on a pu lever pour
ce but ce projet sera reversée à des
associations en faveur de
l'environnement
objectif pour les équipes de parcourir
1000 km en une semaine
retour prévu le vendredi 4 juin à evian
les bains et dans un instant retrouvez
toute l'actualité sportive revinoise
dans l'émission le 7-8 sport présentée
par michael et demi d'euros voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]